ça me croit environ une ou deux heures
pour un registre de ce volume là qui est
en très bon état
bien sûr les registres plus anciens qui
sont beaucoup plus fragiles et allumer
sa demande une manipulation qui est un
petit peu plus lente un petit peu plus
précautionneuse des documents comme
celui ci l'équipe des archives
départementales du loiret on a numérisé
près de 3 millions recueil des registres
annotations contrôle numérisation un
vrai travail de fourmi qui mobilise
depuis quatre ans l'ensemble des trente
agents du service des archives
départementales travail sur cette
opération il y a ceux qui vont chercher
en commune les registres
il y a ceux qui s'occupent de préparer
les registres avant la numérisation
effectuer ce qu'on appelle fichiers de
récolement la préparation puis il y a
ceux qui contrôlent une fois la
numérisation faites par un prestataire
qui contrôle l'ensemble des images qui
vérifie qu'il n'en manque pas avant que
l'on puisse restituer les documents en
commune et cette politique de
numérisation a porté ses fruits avec 33
millions de documents téléchargés le
site des archives a explosé sa
fréquentation en 2014 les documents les
plus consulté les registres d'état civil
et paroissiaux datant d'avant la
révolution et qui font le bonheur des
généalogistes féru d'histoire locale
on peut consulter directement depuis son
ordinateur individuel les documents qui
sont conservés ici même aux archives et
ce à n'importe quelle heure du jour et
de la nuit et et autant de fois qu'on le
veut d'ici 2016 plus d'un million darchy
supplémentaires seront mises en ligne
parmi elles dans la catégorie des
trésors
ce testament de l'oncle du peintre paul
gauguin qui passa plusieurs de ses
jeunes années à orléans